there is one move in chess that is more
spectacular more insane and rarer than
any other chess move it is under
promotion to a bishop now under
promotion happens in chess there are
times when promoting to a queen is not
the right move maybe you need a knight
because of that special hoppy ability
that no other piece has that definitely
happens there are times when promoting
to a queen will create stalemate and so
you need to promote to the next
strongest piece the rook that happens
for example in the most famous chess
study ever the savadra study but why
would you ever need to under promote to
a bishop and not a rook or a knight well
we have five examples right here that
show spectacular examples from real
games where under-promoting to a bishop
was the spectacular winning move
our first example comes from the rapid
chess championship in a recent game that
had live reactions from stunned
commentators here grandmaster david
antongiharo one of the strongest players
from spain has the white pieces and
desperately needs a draw to advance in
this knockout format grand master
kavalav has the black pieces and looks
like he's about to get that win as he
has two pawns nearing promotion however
anton plays the very tricky and
definitely best knight to f1 and in this
position with seconds on the clock
kovalev plays d1 equals queen stalemate
on the board anton gets his draw
advances and the commentators and crowd
are stunned night back to f1 amazing oh
my god you have to oh you should steal
me
you should have made a bishop you could
have flagged him with a bishop oh my
gosh promoting to a rook was also going
to be stalemate because both moves pin
the knight to the king and there's
simply no move for white
the right move here was to underpromote
to a bishop
so spectacular here
now in this position
white's knight is basically getting
trapped and black wins relatively easily
with the two bishops now the knight can
pick off a pawn knight takes h2 picking
off the only pawn but then after king g3
knight f1 king back to f2 the knight can
only go to h2 and bishop e3 is a
zugzwang
in this position the king cannot move
and the knight has no safe move the
knight is falling and black easily wins
now black can under promote to a knight
here and the table bases do tell us that
is a win as well
but it is very very difficult not a
simple position in which to trap the
knight it takes something like 40 moves
to prove the win with a table base so
really practically speaking promoting to
a bishop is the only clear winning move
this example might be the most famous
under promotion
in this position white is to play and if
white promotes to the queen or to the
rook there is the great trick queen to
f7 check
the queen must capture and we have
stalemate as the queen or the rook
controls the last rank and we have a pin
here on that g7 pawn of course the king
is trapped
and backing up if white promotes to a
knight here then there is a prolonged
analysis that shows that the knight is
not able to get out of the corner of
course the white queen wants to help but
the white queen also needs to stop queen
f7 checkmate so it seems there is no way
to make progress with the knight trapped
on the edge just like this
so the only winning move proves to be a8
equals the classic bishop now there is
no stalemate the bishop is headed to d5
and white wins in very very short order
our next example is from the soviet
championship of 1983.
it is black to play in the game holmath
versus elvist and black is ready to
promote as the pawns are advancing in
this direction but what do you promote
too
if you promote to a queen then white has
rook to a8 check the queen captures and
this is the stalemate
but if you back up and promote to a rook
then you actually fare worse because
after promoting to a rook when we get
the check the king has to move white
promotes and mates in short order
promoting to a night also allows the
check and promotion
so the only move
is to promote to the bishop again the
spectacular under promotion the bishop
controls the square without allowing any
stalemate tricks so black is basically
up a bishop and went on to win this game
this next example is even more recent
than the rapid chess championship
example i showed earlier this game is
from the reykjavik open this year 2022
yes the year 2022 seems to be the year
of the bishop under promotion
here grand master here tarson with the
white pieces seemed to miss what looked
to be a fairly direct winning effort as
pointed out on twitter white can play
the move queen to f7 check which is very
pretty but not too difficult to
calculate right after queen f7 check we
have knight takes pawn takes with a fork
right here the king cannot move over to
f8 because after king f8 you simply have
knight to g6 and the queen must
sacrifice itself for the knight
otherwise it would be checkmate
however after pawn takes f7 check there
is king h7
this must have been seen by both players
and they decided that this was not
winning because if white captures here
and promotes to a queen then black has
queen g2
or
queen to h1 and giving up the queen
creates stalemate a really incredible
resource
but backing up
in this position after king h7 you can't
promote to a rook or a knight because
then you will leave this rook on d7
hanging
but you can promote to the bishop
once again another brilliant bishop
under promotion now the rook is defended
critical and we have the idea simply of
bishop to g6 and mates along the back
rank and we are also just winning on
material beautiful spectacular and again
an incredibly recent example
our examples so far have not been too
difficult to calculate unique special
gorgeous positions but not too difficult
to calculate but this example from the
soviet union in 1938 between sokolsky
and ravinsky is very very complicated
computer analysis really won't help you
here and there are just pages and pages
to show that in this position
only one move wins for white
now as you may suspect it is not
promoting here to a queen because after
promoting to a queen black has a
rampaging rook the rook will force white
to capture it and eventually when white
does capture it it will be stalemate
here because the bishop is pinned and
the pawns are blocked and the king has
no move
now we have the same resource
if white promotes to a rook again it
will be still mate and also a knight is
not good enough here rook c8 traps the
knight and if white tries to defend the
knight with rook a6 then you just take
it and rook takes a8 is again stalemate
so
the only good under promotion here that
does not create these stalemates is a8
equals bishop as you might have guessed
however
in this position white wins
patiently by slowly progressing with the
b-pawn and there's no way to ultimately
create stalemate
the big question is
does white have to promote here i mean
this still requires some effort to win
could you instead hear just play a move
like pawn to b4
and
eventually you can promote
well again there are pages and pages of
analysis and we are not going to unpack
all of it but the analysis does show
that in this position black is able to
sit tight in the idea of continuing to
sacrifice the rook if white promotes to
a queen or a rook is so powerful that
there is no way to ultimately win for
white the stalemates do save the day and
so as a result white does need to commit
to the under promotion to a bishop
each of the five examples i've shown
thus far do come from real games but i
have one bonus example my personal
favorite chess study ever this is a
study by deller in 1921 and even though
it is a chess study it could definitely
come from a real game you would never
know that this was a chess study just by
looking at this position it's an
entirely feasible bishop in game
now here white cannot dilly dally so you
must push the pawn pawn to d7 and hey
you're ready to promote on the next turn
so you're just winning right
well it's not so simple because of
bishop e8 absolutely the best defense
and a very very good try
now here of course you can't capture the
bishop because having only a bishop
remaining isn't enough to win the game
and promoting to a queen or a rook
creates immediate stalemate with the
white bishop cutting off the king's move
and the queen of course pinning the
bishop
so
backing up what about promoting to a
knight in this position well that's not
good enough because there is one move
and only one move that saves black the
bishop is almost trapped for example you
cannot go bishop h5 because after 96
check wherever the king moves you have
either a fork on g7 if you go to e8 or a
discovery after king g8 knight f4 check
you win the bishop and you do have to
show your bishop at night check mating
technique but white is winning
however after promoting to a knight
there is bishop a4 running to the edge
of the board the bishop cannot now be
picked off and white is not able to win
this position with bishop and knight
versus bishop
so
you must play d8 equals bishop
and here there are just the two bishops
remaining against the one bishop and
that should not normally win but here
there are checkmates in the air it's a
really beautiful pure two bishops first
one bishop position
and now of course the black bishop needs
to move if you go bishop to a4 bishop f7
so quiet so deadly the black bishop
moves and then you have bishop to e7
check
mate
backing up what if the bishop doesn't go
to a4 and instead tries to go over to h5
after bishop to h5 you have bishop e7
check and then the king steps over and
you have bishop to b5 a very different
also beautiful checkmate
everything
works together perfectly i hope you like
this study because again it is my
favorite chess study of all time it's so
simple so efficient so perfect
well
here are some incredible examples of
bishop under promotion you may have
noticed a theme yes the only reason that
i know of that it would only be correct
to promote to a bishop in a position
is because of stalemate if anyone knows
of any reason you would ever promote to
a bishop that is not stalemate related i
would love to see it if you want to see
more of the great videos we post here at
chess.com simply click on the playlist
that is popping up on your screen
you